do using their MP set a good example by
shouting and calling each other names in
the House of Commons well I take a
slightly different view from lots of
people on this and I know when you see
it on television it can look very rowdy
and people are shouting at each other
and they're grown-ups is there probably
not as well behaved as you are in your
classes but this is where I disagree
with some people actually the issues
we're talking about are really important
to people's lives and they're important
for our country important in the world
and people feel very strongly about them
and they don't always agree you know you
will not even agree amongst yourselves
on some important issues and you might
disagree with some of the members of
your family about things and that's
natural and that's what it means to be
in a democracy and so I'd much rather
have a House of Commons a farmer which
its lively and people feel passionately
about things then a really quiet place
if you ever watch on television like the
Parliament or so-called Parliament of a
country like North Korea which is a
dictatorship it's totally silent and all
they do is they applaud the the leader
of North Korea so in our country we're
lucky to have really lively debates
people feel very strongly about it and
if you've got a view you can make your
view hurt just what do you think do you
think it's a good example set in the
comments and well it is really a matter
of opinion i think because i think that
it's good for like adults but maybe not
so good for children if they're watching
it because they think it might be okay
to shell and express their opinion in a
way that isn't very suitable for their
age